há cinco anos discutindo dilemas
profissionais com um amigo
mikhail uma ficha eu sempre pensei na
área social como uma área paralela tem
tudo o que você faz no seu dia se estuda
trabalha demais e aí tem o que você faz
para o social naquele tempo ele livre
naquele intervalo
há cinco anos foi a primeira vez que eu
pensei que pessoas trabalham com isso e
que eu poderia trabalhar com isso foi
uma mudança de olhar de encarar uma
coisa como algo para horas vagas
despretensioso muitas vezes até
descompromissado para olhar para aquilo
como uma possível carreira eu realmente
nunca tinha pensado que esse era um
setor com o mercado profissional
meu mundo aumentou de tamanho em um
monte de possibilidades novas surgiram
com uma mudança de olhar eu comecei
então a trilhar um caminho de mudança
estava no ambiente corporativo que eu
gostava do que fazia
mas eu não imaginava ficando lá por
muito tempo
e aí pensar como então eu poderia migrar
para essa carreira que eu não sabia como
era no mercado que estava se delineando
pra mim e aí eu tenho um caminho que eu
conhecia eu fui buscar quais eram as
habilidades e qual o conhecimento que eu
precisava comprová-la que as portas se
abrirem para mim e aí um ano e meio
depois dessa primeira mudança de olhar
uma nova mudança de olhar eu percebi que
eu mesmo poderia abrir as portas e ao
invés de ficar tendo buscando essas
habilidades e conhecimento e ter como
ponto de partida experiências
profissionais que eu ainda nem tinha
então estava tipo assim super precisando
construir um caminho para construir um
caminho novo
eu comecei a pensar que o ponto de
partida poderia ser eu o meu jeito o que
eu acredito
a minha identidade a minha bagunça de
cabelo do meu amor
e foi exatamente o meu jeito que eu
acredito que eu gosto e também
habilidade
a dis e o conhecimento que eu já tinha
que me levou junto com também quem era
eo jeito de amar campanati da maria
ribeiro e do thiago a construir juntos o
projeto imagina copa
eu acho que também é a nossa capacidade
de criar e se apaixonar por uma idéia
desde o começo e principalmente de pedir
ajuda que fez com que esse projeto
ganhasse vida imagina na copa ele surgiu
em 2012 ele propõe uma inversão de um
sentimento negativo para o movimento
positivo a partir da mobilização
envolvimento de jovens em iniciativas de
impacto de novo uma mudança de olhar
isso ao invés de reclamar
a gente se organizar para fazer dar
certo materializado na própria frase
imagina na copa que na época era usada
como sinônimo de todo o apocalipse tudo
que ia dar errado em 2014 que na época
era futuro ea gente propôs uma inversão
imagina mas imagino contrário imagina
que vai ser bom
imagina que vai ser bom porque você fez
parte disso ao invés de focar no que não
funciona e no quintal errado e no
aeroporto e no trânsito e reclamar e
aquela espiral que contagem de e de
repente está todo mundo falando mal de
alguma coisa você nem percebe por quanto
tempo a gente vê uma oportunidade ea
gente achou que já estava no futuro a
gente poderia usar a copa do mundo como
uma desculpa para promover
transformações significativas e
duradouras pra gente
os brasileiros para o brasil
independente do evento mas como uma
mudança de olhar de novo a gente não viu
esse caminho por meio de organizações
marcas governo projetos mirabolantes
apesar de entender respeitar o papel ea
importância de cada um deles
a gente foi para as pessoas as pessoas
transformam as decisões individuais são
muito importantes
a decisão entre deixar o carro em casa o
ônibus metrô bicicleta ela poderia
acabar com o trânsito de são paulo
hoje talvez não hoje está chovendo é dia
de chuva em são paulo especialmente
desafiadores mas é é porque alguém
escolhe e de um jeito ou de outro que a
gente se depara depois com um problema
que quando todo mundo a maioria opta por
carro engarrafamento mas se optar por
metrô ônibus é outra coisa talvez metrô
tivesse que estender as horas talvez a
gente tivesse que duplicar linhas de
ônibus mas é uma decisão
eu sempre penso naquele botão vermelho
de filme americano que está havendo uma
caixa de acrílico com um superministro
gigante megas assina aqui do lado e aí
alguém vai abrir aquele negócio aperta o
botão esse exemplo coisa porque alguém
aperta o botão antigos ele tanto pará no
miss you é sempre alguém que vai lá e
aperta um botão e tudo bem agora eu acho
que talvez seja tipo um botão eletrônico
talvez seja tipo um áudio no o tap mas
assim alguém faz alguma coisa e vai
disparar no início eu sempre fico
pensando nessa imagem é uma decisão é
uma decisão ser gentil ou da preferência
é uma decisão comprar esse ou aquele
produto é uma decisão jogar bituca de
cigarro no chão é uma decisão
compartilhar um vídeo que a gente
recebeu de alguém que não sabia que
estava sendo filmado
é uma decisão se informar um pouco
melhor antes de emitir uma opinião
são decisões de pessoas que fazem a
diferença o tempo inteiro e aí mais uma
mudança de olhar se a gente percebe que
a gente é parte do todo e por fazer
parte do todo
a gente também é responsável por ele a
gente percebe quantas vezes a gente age
de forma inconsciente e não se dá conta
do resultado dessas ações e muitas vezes
a gente acaba contribuindo para agravar
problemas que incomodam a gente mesmo a
gente aperta o botão vermelho para
michel e nem percebe
a gente acredita nas pessoas como agente
de transformação e foi nesse universo de
pessoas que promovem transformações que
a gente teve mérito por quase dois anos
em que durou o projeto
agendamos uma equipe de quatro pessoas
uma mudança de olhar a gente abre o
projeto
passamos a contar com mais 78 jovens
voluntários espalhados por todo o brasil
representando o projeto localmente com
total autonomia ea gente descobre que
deixar de ser fechado para semiaberto e
perdeu o controle
só fez o projeto fica mais relevante e
maior e chegar em mais lugares
e aí a gente descobriu que confiar se
paga e vale muito muito a pena
durante dois anos em que o projeto
aconteceu nós circulamos os 27 estados
do brasil
mapeando documentando histórias de
jovens das mais diversas que estavam
promovendo transformações locais
daline ensinando surf para os meninos da
vila de ponta negra na praia de ponta
negra em natal
gabriel promovendo roda de conversa
sobre política e formatando projetos e
fazendo uma interlocução com os agentes
políticos do acre em rio branco do ruch
com o simão eo márcio promovendo
mutirões que eram verdadeiras festas
para limpar a praia e usar isso como uma
desculpa para falar de meio ambiente de
lixo de consumo
foram 75 curtas documentários contando
histórias como essas de 150 jovens 19
missões que é um desafio super simples
de serem realizados e que gerava o
impacto no final e uma oficina de oito
horas com metodologia conteúdo aberto
para que qualquer pessoa pudesse
replicar essa oficina a gente sabe hoje
ela chegou em quase 500 municípios e 10%
dos municípios do brasil e sim muita
coisa imagina na copa foi um projeto
impulsionado por mudança de olhares
mudança de olhar é uma coisa simbólica é
sutil mas é algo extraordinário
segundo jeito de olhar o mundo inteiro
muda a sua experiência de mundo muda a
noção do que é possível muda como
mudança de olhar de fazer um projeto
você sabe pra fazer um projeto a partir
de quem você é de reclamar e focar no
que não funciona pra ver oportunidade e
preocupações de pessoas que estão na
sociedade para pessoas que transformam e
criam a sociedade de fechado para aberto
de equipe para a rede
com o início da copa do mundo o projeto
acabou mas como todo mundo não fica sem
assunto muito tempo logo vêm as eleições
parece que tá rolando aquele super
debate e que está todo mundo a fim de
participar
galera animada brasileiros finalmente
gostam de política mas vai passando o
tempo pan
a coisa vai afunilando os ânimos vão se
anime crescendo e aí quando você vê é um
tal de deletar coleguinha de rede social
e divulgar para todo mundo que você tá
deletando colega da rede social numa
limpeza ideológica se cercando de gente
que pensa igual a você como eu nunca
tinha vista e de repente era azul contra
vermelho e vermelho contra azul e todo
mundo torcendo pro outro tropeçar
a culpa não é minha eu voltei fulano a
você apoia uma quadrilha você apoia a
violência
você não acha que eu tinha o direito de
ser livre são ideias perigosas essas são
idéias que separam torcendo contra o
outro e mais perigoso é que elas estavam
sendo jogadas com muita certeza cheia de
certo e errado com muita sentença
público que pode ter certeza que estou
falando aqui a ser muito molhada tudo
nós estamos construindo as pessoas
transformam com o que pode ter certeza
que pode torcer contra o outro quem é o
outro a gente divide mesmo que de forma
desigual
o mesmo planeta a gente deu quando então
que o espírito que levou à criação de
imagem na copa ele estava e ainda ainda
estava pulsando o projeto acabou que a
gente ainda precisa de referência de
saber o que existe o projeto que podem
ampliados que podem ser replicadas que
podem ser aumentados
a gente ainda precisa de bons exemplos e
boas notícias vive se encantar com o
mundo precisa olhar pra ele ver beleza a
gente ia gostar dele não cuida de alguma
coisa que a gente não gosta a gente que
quer que ele seja melhor amanhã a gente
tem que se encantar com as pessoas não
conseguiu encantar com uma pessoa como
eu vou querer conversar com ela um
diálogo como a gente aprende a escutar
como a gente colabora como a gente
constrói junto a gente ainda precisa de
pontos de vista em entender que o que a
gente sabe o que a gente afirma com
certeza está baseada no que a gente
aprendeu e na forma como a gente
aprendeu mas outras pessoas aprenderam
outras coisas de outro jeito porque
viver outras coisas então como que eu
posso ter minha opinião mas eu fico
atento a minha opinião e eu me permite
eu permaneça aberto para o novo a gente
ainda precisa de caminhos para a ação
como então que materializa energia e
essa vontade em coisas concretas para o
mundo como é que a gente começar a agir
com consciência e entende o resultado
como que se transforma um todo
e mais como falar de problema e
responsabilidade e futuro sujeito leve
divertido e colorido sem ficar colocando
aquela pressão para dar aquela angústia
esse é o nosso jeito a gente viu então
que o espírito eo motivo pelo qual
imagem da copa surgiu ainda estava vivo
e aí a gente volta
quase um ano depois com um novo chamado
chamado agora não é mais para jovens
transformarem o brasil para um futuro
próximo
o chamado agora é pra todo mundo
transformar já chamada agora imagina
você eu queria compartilhar um vídeo que
apresenta um pouco desse espírito
o mundo é um dividimos ainda que de
maneira desigual
o mesmo planeta e por isso é preciso
tornar um lugar melhor pra todo mundo é
o último a nossa complexidade enquanto
em dívidas é maior que a polarização
mulheres e homens ricos e pobres
comunistas e capitalistas e por isso é
preciso superar as categorias mundo
mutante todo dia no futuro se torna
presente e por isso é preciso agir hoje
e não esperar
então imagina imagina mais lugares
transformados a partir de ações simples
imagina mais pessoas colaborando e
abraçando a diversidade
imagina mais projetos construídos
pensando bem comum
imagina mais mão na massa ao invés de
apontar o que não funciona
imagina mais confiança em si mesmo mais
referências do que é possível mais
caminhos em andamento
imagine imaginar o começo de tudo
mas é só o começo
o mundo a gente cria um mundo você cria
agora imagina você
hum
imagina você é uma evolução da imagem na
copa
a gente vai continuar produzindo
conteúdo com referência ponto de vista
que a administração só que agora somando
outros produtores de conteúdo para
ampliar rede e agora conteúdo sobre
temas temas que são importantes para a
gente
reforma política a maioridade penal mas
também de pressão privacidade diferença
entre gerações assunto importante pra
gente como sociedade com pessoas assunto
que vale apenas se tornarem assunto e
que talvez mereçam uma mudança de olhar
eu fico muito feliz de dizer que a gente
fez uma campanha de financiamento
coletivo pedindo dinheiro numa época de
crise e 454 pessoas apoiaram e agora
fazem parte desse time junto com a gente
o convite agora imagina você você você
como você vê o mundo hoje que 10 você
tem reproduzido que você nem se dá conta
de que elas não são suas
que votou em vermelho a gente tem
apertado como você passa a enxergar em
você
o poder de transformação que a gente
enxerga e como é que você pode começar a
construir hoje o mundo que você imagina
obrigado